Smart plus. Guys, what are they? Listen, I'm gonna be the first to wish you happy Christmas Eve. Yeah, more. Yeah, happy Christmas Eve more to you guys. What are you guys gonna do tonight? You know what we're gonna do? We're all gonna see each other right now.
Smartless。大家，这是什么？听着，我是第一个祝你们平安夜快乐的人。对，更多。对，祝你们平安夜更多快乐。你们今晚打算做什么？你知道我们要去做什么吗？我们现在都要见面了。
Yeah, a hunt. Christmas Eve. Now, I'm not gonna see you guys tonight because I'm not with you guys right now. Oh, well, that's okay. We'll just do anyway. were we're gonna zoom in. Let's make this a let's make this a little our little family Trish that no matter what we do a little zoom sees with our fans and stuff. Yeah, I would like that I would love that. Let's do it. I'm gonna do it. You guys have an ugly Christmas sweater I went to an ugly Christmas sweater party once and I went on Etsy and bought one for like
对，狩猎。平安夜。现在，我今晚见不到你们，因为我现在没有和你们在一起。哦，好吧，没关系。反正我们都会做的。我们要进行视频连线。让我们把这变成一个让我们的小家庭传统，无论我们做什么，都要和我们的粉丝进行一次视频连线之类的。是的，我很乐意，我很喜欢那样。我们做吧。我要这么做。你们有一件丑陋的圣诞毛衣吗？我曾经去过一个丑陋的圣诞毛衣派对，我去Etsy上买了一件，大概花了我
Freaking $300. It like plugs into a battery pack and everything. It's got lights and stuff on it. Really? Yeah, I might dust that thing off and break it out. I'm not a big fan of the ugly Christmas sweater thing. But I will say this, I do own one that somebody had made for me. It's really nice.
整整300美元。它甚至还有插电池的插头什么的。上面有灯光之类的。真的吗？是的，我可能会把那东西拿出来掸掸灰尘，穿上它。我不太喜欢丑陋的圣诞毛衣这回事。但我得说，我的确有一件别人为我定制的。它真的很不错。
That's just a sweater. And it says, Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill himself. But like in nice Christmas-y letters, I swear to God. It's really nice. That's just a sweater. And it says, Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill himself. But like in nice Christmasy letters, I swear to God, it's really cool. Oh wow. Speaking of sweaters, by the way, it's Christmas Eve. It is Christmas Eve, and I do want to say this. My mom has been asking me a lot about the sweaters
那只是一件毛衣。上面写着，杰弗里·爱泼斯坦没有自杀。但用的却是那种很好看的圣诞风格的字体，我向上帝发誓。它真的很不错。那只是一件毛衣。上面写着，杰弗里·爱泼斯坦没有自杀。但用的却是那种很好看的圣诞风格的字体，我向上帝发誓，它真的很酷。哦，哇。说到毛衣，顺便说一句，今天是平安夜。确实是平安夜，我确实想说这个。我妈妈一直在问我很多关于毛衣的事
that she needed for both you guys. She needed me a real fetching vest. Yes. And she wants photos. Well, you guys do me a favor. We'll make her Christmas morning. If I can tomorrow morning show her a picture from each of you just wearing this. Do you think I'm going to give your mother a picture of me in a sweater vest so she can
她为你们俩准备的。她需要我带一件非常别致的背心。是的。而且她想要照片。好吧，你们帮我个忙。如果明天早上我能给她看一张你们俩分别穿着这件衣服的照片，我们就会让她过一个愉快的圣诞早晨。你觉得我会给你母亲一张我穿着毛衣背心的照片，好让她
go off and do her mad posting like she's so known for? She's so mad. Oh my goodness. To social media profile on her. She's not posting any more. She wants to see. She spent weeks knitting those sweaters for you guys. I'll totally do that.
去发疯似地发帖，就像她那么出名做的那样吗？她太疯狂了。哦，天哪。关于她的社交媒体个人资料。她不会再发帖了。她想看看。她花了好几个星期为你们织这些毛衣。我完全可以做到。
Wait, do you guys open gifts on Christmas Eve or Christmas? Christmas. We'll do one on Christmas Eve, but we'll be recording. Yeah, we'll release the valve a little bit. A little bit for the kids, yeah. Yeah, we don't. Oh, yeah. But we'll do Christmas morning.
等等，你们是在平安夜还是圣诞节拆礼物？圣诞节。我们会在平安夜拆一个，但我们会录制。对，我们会稍微释放一下压力。为了孩子们，稍微释放一点，对。是的，我们不会。哦，是的。但我们会在圣诞早晨拆。
And it's just a matter of tomorrow morning, it's going to be, keep, especially the littles, keeping them from just... Just want to be able to get past 8.30 in the morning, we know, without all the gifts unwrapped and like, well, now what do we do? You know, like, just stretch it out a little bit? Yeah, and watch TV, it's just another day. It ends up being just another day.
明天早上，主要就是，特别是对小孩子们来说，不让让他们……只是想能熬到早上8点半，你知道的，不要还没拆完所有礼物就说，好吧，现在我们该做什么？你知道的，就是稍微拖延一下时间？对，看电视，它也就是普通的一天。结果它也只是又一个普通的日子。
Just another day to watch TV. So like, when Sean, every time Sean buys a new house, it's just another place to watch TV. Yeah. Yeah. It is really true. I mean, if any link I've ever seen of any piece of real estate, it's always like, where's the TV room? Yeah, I know, I said.
只是又一个看电视的日子。所以，当肖恩每次买新房子时，那也只是又一个看电视的地方。对。是的。这真的是千真万确。我的意思是，我见过的任何房产的任何链接，总是像在问：电视房在哪里？是的，我知道，我说了。
Where would I be watching TV? It's like when we're on tour. Remember every time we go into any hotel, Jason would find the couch that was perpendicular to the TV. We have to remote, and he's like, this is my spot. Mm-hmm. Well, you know what, and he's like, this is my spot. Mm-hmm. Well, you know what, on Christmas,
我在哪里可以看电视？就像我们巡演的时候一样。还记得每次我们走进任何酒店，杰森总是会找到那张与电视垂直的沙发吗？我们必须得拿到遥控器，然后他说，这是我的位置。嗯。好吧，你知道吗，然后他说，这是我的位置。嗯。好吧，你知道吗，在圣诞节，
you can do whatever you want. And Christmas is such a magical time of the year. And I feel really blessed that we got our guests who we got today. And that we do have somebody here who knows a thing or two about Christmas. This is somebody who lives way up North. Oh, we're the most part of this. Is the North Pole, about Christmas. This is somebody who lives way up North.
你想做什么都可以。而且圣诞节是一年中如此神奇的时刻。我感到非常幸运，我们今天请到了嘉宾。而且我们这里确实有一位对圣诞节略知一二的人。这是一个住在极北之地的人。哦，我们最北部的地方。就是北极，关于圣诞节。这是一个住在极北之地的人。
In the northernmost part of those. Is the North Pole. We are so lucky without further ado. You guys, it's Santa Claus. What? We're talking to Santa Claus. It's a real Santa. Santa. Santa, this is the thing.
在那些地方的最北部。就是北极。我们太幸运了，废话不多说。伙计们，是圣诞老人！什么？我们在和圣诞老人说话。是个真正的圣诞老人。圣诞老人。圣诞老人，事情是这样的。
So you're just resting up before he's smoking a butt. Oh, okay. Oh, what are you guys? Listen, I don't have a lot of time, right? At least, at least Persian. No, I'm not Persian. What are you talking about? St. Nicholas.
所以你只是在抽烟屁股之前休息一下。哦，好吧。哦，你们是什么？听着，我没有那么多时间，好吗？至少，至少是波斯人。不，我不是波斯人。你在说什么？圣尼古拉。
A Serbian. I'm Serbian. I'm Serbian. Nick and Diad of everyone. St. Alexander Claus is an American English whatever. Look in the history books. He's always been Serbian. Okay.
一个塞尔维亚人。我是塞尔维亚人。我是塞尔维亚人。尼克和每个人的迪亚德。圣亚历山大·克劳斯是一个英国裔美国人什么的。去翻翻历史书吧。他一直都是塞尔维亚人。好吧。
Nick St. Nick. So. St. Nicholas. St. Nick Alive. He's always been Serbian. Okay. St. Nicky. So... St. Nicholas. St. Nickyly. He's Serbian. From the Nicholas light of tree, where the family is from Belgrade and you know, it's always been Serbian. But look, I don't have a lot of fucking time, huh?
尼克，圣尼克。所以。圣尼古拉。圣尼克还活着。他一直都是塞尔维亚人。好吧。小尼基。所以……圣尼古拉。圣尼基利。他是塞尔维亚人。来自尼古拉的家族之树，家族来自贝尔格莱德，你知道的，他一直都是塞尔维亚人。但是听着，我没有那么多该死的时间，哈？
Oh, God. Is it true that you're slay to get pulled by goats then instead of me then instead of when we early days, it's all we had and then my fifth cousin, he said, what about the reindeer? And just stop that stop of his head. But like, like sure, we can eat them. He's like, no, no, no, they can fly. And shut up, shut up. Why do you have reading glasses on? You're not reading anything. I don't look, go, hold I am, go. Every day I wake up in a bowl of pain, okay?
哦，天哪。传闻你的雪橇以前是由山羊拉的，而不是由鲁道夫，这是真的吗？早期的时候，我们只有山羊，然后我的第五代堂弟说，驯鹿怎么样？然后他就一拍脑袋。就像，当然，我们可以吃它们。他说，不，不，不，它们会飞。闭嘴，闭嘴。你为什么戴着老花镜？你又没在读什么东西。我没有，听着，去，我老了，去。我每天醒来都浑身是痛，好吧？
And I can't see four feet in front of my face. So, Sarah, you got a hell of a night. You're like glasses? You got a real, you got a hell of a knife. You're like glasses? You got a real, you got a hell of a knife ahead of you. I mean, this is your day. This is your biggest day of the year, right, Sam? This without question. What kind of question is that?
而且我连眼前四英尺的东西都看不清。所以，萨拉，你今晚可有一场硬仗要打。你戴着眼镜？你真的有一场——你今晚有一场硬仗要打。我是说，这是你的日子。这是你一年中最盛大的日子，对吧，萨姆？毫无疑问。这算什么问题？
Well, I can't come on a day of the year that counts. And, you know, let me tell you something, this strike fucked us, okay? Okay. Because here's what happened. You guys, you know, you do your strikes and everyone loves Hollywood and then the elves start getting ideas. Are they trying to organize?
好吧，我可不能挑一年中不重要的日子来。而且，我告诉你，这次罢工把我们害惨了，好吗？好吧。因为事情是这样的。你们这些家伙，你知道的，你们搞罢工，每个人都喜欢好莱坞，然后小精灵们就开始有想法了。他们是在试图组织起来吗？
Elves totally organized and look, I can't do what I do without the elves. There's no question. Okay, so I respect them. Sure, but be honest. But be honest, what else is an elf going to do? It's the only they don't have any other job skills. Right. They can do. They could do. They could do stand in work for young actors.
小精灵们完全组织起来了，听着，没有小精灵我什么也做不了。这是毫无疑问的。好吧，所以我尊重他们。当然，但说实话。但说实话，小精灵还能做什么？这是唯一的——他们没有任何其他工作技能。对。他们能做什么。他们可以。他们可以为年轻演员做替身工作。
I guess. Yeah. I guess. Wait, Santa, Santa, are you are you willing to go on record with us? Did the elves did friend Dresher get to the elves friend? You know what? Let's that isn't, I dropped my sitter. If I think it's in your beard, you're on a higher set. Fran Drescher, that is a dirty word in our health folk, Fran Drescher.
我猜吧。对。我猜吧。等等，圣诞老人，圣诞老人，你愿意跟我们正式谈谈吗？小精灵们——德雷斯琪（Fran Drescher）联系过小精灵吗，弗兰？你知道吗？那不是——我把我的假牙掉了。如果我觉得它在你的胡子里，你就在更高的布景里。弗兰·德雷斯琪，在我们小精灵的圈子里，这是一个脏话，弗兰·德雷斯琪。
She got them all riled up and then next thing, you know, okay, so. Here we go. It's always been standard. They get like four, four sugar plums. Right. They wanted a break. They wanted, you know, they wanted standardized working hours. They wanted to, instead of a 22 hour day, they wanted 21. And they concerned about AI at all. Well, AI is, it's here to stay. Yeah. Yeah.
她把他们全都煽动起来了，接下来你知道的，好吧，就这样。一直都是标准做法。他们得到大约四颗、四颗糖果梅。对。他们想要休息。他们想要，你知道的，他们想要标准化的工作时间。他们想要——与其一天工作22个小时，不如变成21个小时。他们对人工智能有什么担忧吗？嗯，人工智能，它已经存在了。对。对。
So you got. That's a remote. You got a log starter to like, wow, when did you start smoking? I got to tell you that I not until the last 10 years because you know what the number one gift now is. What's it? High end mattresses. Yes, nectar. So I got a load mattresses.
所以你有了。那是一个遥控器。你甚至还有一个火种点燃器，哇，你什么时候开始抽烟的？我得告诉你，我直到最近10年才开始，因为你知道现在最热门的礼物是什么吗？是什么？高端床垫。是的，Nectar（床垫）。所以我得运送床垫。
So, boy. That's a lot of space on the display, I bet. It goes anything from Paw Patrol and Bluey. And then the number three is mattresses. That's everyone's list. They want a high-end mattress. So, I'm like fine. But do you realize how much time and effort, I mean that?
所以，天哪。我敢说，陈列架上有很大一部分空间都被它占据了。从《汪汪队立大功》和《布鲁伊》应有尽有。然后第三名就是床垫。那是每个人的愿望清单。他们想要一张高端床垫。所以，我只好照办。但你知道这需要多少时间和精力吗，我是说那个？
I can only imagine. I'm cramming mattress through door. I'm like, I'm busting off windows. I'm tearing through French doors. Anything to get in the mattress in. Because they don't go down the chimney. All the you go down the chimney, right? You can't roll them up and put them down there like this.
我只能想象。我把床垫硬塞进门。我砸碎窗户。我撞穿法式双开门。不惜一切代价把床垫塞进去。因为它们塞不进烟囱。所有的——你都是从烟囱下去的，对吧？你不能把它们卷起来然后像这样从那儿塞下去。
Yes. And what's crazy is a lot of mattress guys, they're like, they won't do flights as stairs. They get to the house and they're like, no, we don't. And the ass won't for sure. So I've got three mattresses strapped in my back. And I am, I am this close to, you know, calling it. No.
是的。而且疯狂的是，很多送床垫的家伙，他们就像是，他们不肯爬楼梯。他们到了房子门口就说，不，我们不干。小精灵们也绝对不干。所以我背上绑着三个床垫。而且我，我差一点就要，你知道的，不干了。不。
Yes. Well, so then you do, you're kind of, I am this close. I am this close. I call it quick. This close. This could be the last year. Wow. There's a very good chance.
是的。好吧，所以你正在——你是那种，我差一点就。我差一点就。我打算不干了。就差这么点。这可能是最后一年了。哇。很有这个可能。
Well, do you do any sort of level motion? I'm not saying revolutionize the mattress. What if you just bring a bunch of yoga mats? You think people will go for that instead? I guess. Maybe. Now, what kind of, do you do any carbo loading today? I don't want to, I don't want a ton of, I don't want a ton of ladders to the North Pole
好吧，你有没有做过某种程度的革命？我不是说彻底革新床垫。如果你只带一堆瑜伽垫呢？你觉得人们会用那个来代替吗？我猜吧。也许吧。现在，你今天吃什么类型的碳水化合物来补充体力？我不想，我不想有成吨的，我不想有成吨的来自北极的电话，
telling me that elves can't do anything but work on toys and build mattresses. Okay, I don't want to hear about it. No, dude. Okay. We'll reinforce that afterwards. Santa, how do you spend your time after you deliver all the toys and the gifts and everything? How do you, what's your down? Hold on.
告诉我小精灵除了制作玩具和建造床垫什么也做不了。好吧，我不想听到这些。不，老兄。好吧。我们之后会加强这一点。圣诞老人，送完所有的玩具、礼物和一切之后，你如何消磨时间？你如何——你如何放松？等等。
Hold on. Hold on. I need to pay the bills. I'm sorry. Oh, here comes an ad. There's DNA. Then there's heavy duty DNA, H-DNA. It's whatever G-M-C-C-R-H-D-E-N-S-B-O-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L to prove it. To hitches of the world. Prepare for glory. Prepare for glory. Wait, are you, do you endorse, do you work for GMC? Yes, I work for GMC. I guess who doesn't? Do you?
等等。等等。我得付账单。对不起。哦，广告来了。然后是重型DNA，H-DNA。无论是什么G-M-C-C-R-H-D-E-N-S-B-O-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L来证明。献给全世界的挂钩。准备好迎接荣耀。准备好迎接荣耀。等等，你，你是代言人吗，你为GMC工作吗？是的，我为GMC工作。猜猜谁不为他们工作？你吗？
Not anymore. I guess not. Yeah, I'm out of that read. You said a GMC slay that you're rocking? Did I get a thumbs up from your audio team? Do you think that? It was good. It came through. So we got a perfect. Clean, guys, is it clean?
不再是了。我想不是吧。是的，我已经不接那个广告了。你刚才说你开的是一辆GMC雪橇？我得到你音频团队的竖大拇指了吗？你觉得呢？挺好的。声音传过来了。所以我们做得很完美。很干净，伙计们，干净吗？
Yeah, it's super, super clean. It came through perfect. Great. Thank you. Sean, Sean, I have a great question. My question is, do you have any sort of prep that you do to get ready for tonight as far as like stretching out or eating a bunch of carbs? And then Sean, one of the know what do you do to get ready for tonight as far as like, you know, stretching out or eating a bunch of carbs.
对，超级、超级干净。声音传得完美无缺。太棒了。谢谢。肖恩，肖恩，我有一个很好的问题。我的问题是，为了今晚的行动，你在做准备时有没有做什么热身，比如拉伸或者吃大量的碳水化合物？然后肖恩，想知道——为了今晚的行动，你在做准备时有没有做什么，比如，你知道的，拉伸或者吃大量的碳水化合物。
And then Sean wanted to know what do you do to relax after your big night. Like do you have a spa day tomorrow? I'll do, yeah, definitely do a cold blunge tomorrow. Do a cold blunge. That's just right there outside the house up north. Mostly I just have a lot of lists. I have a lot of coordinates navigating. I have to figure out, you know, I've got, Jason,
然后肖恩想知道你在度过这个盛大的夜晚后是如何放松的。比如你明天会有个水疗日吗？我会的，是的，明天绝对会做个冷水浴。做个冷水浴。就在北极房子外面的那个。大部分时间我只是有很多份清单。我有很多坐标要导航。我得弄清楚，你知道的，我有——杰森，
I don't know if you know I have to do the whole world in one night, okay? So, I've got to get my docks in a row, and in fact, it's unbelievable that I'm talking to you right now. We've really appreciated time. Do you ever wear anything else besides that outfit, or is that the outfit you wear every single time? Sean, I have to tell you something.
我不知道你知不知道我必须在一个晚上走遍全世界，好吧？所以，我得把我的文件整理好，事实上，能和你们说话真是难以置信。我们真的很感激这段时间。除了那套衣服，你还穿过别的吗？还是说那就是你每次都穿的衣服？肖恩，我得告诉你一件事。
I don't know the other two so much, but you, my friend, you are very talented. Growing up in Serbia as a young man, we only had two channels. And we loved you in three's company. I mean, what you did, that was a very subversive show. We knew all the things you guys were saying.
另外两个人我不太了解，但你，我的朋友，你非常才华横溢。作为一个年轻人在塞尔维亚长大的时候，我们只有两个频道。而且我们很喜欢你在《三人行》（Three's Company）里的表现。我是说，你所做的一切，那是一个非常颠覆性的节目。我们知道你们说的一切。
Yes, sir. And the commentary on American propaganda and consumerism and the fact that Jack was a spy for the US government. Thank you. Well, thank you for getting it. Thank you for getting it. And just, right, and everything behind, I remember the son, all the kisses are hers and his and hers.
是的，先生。还有对美国宣传和消费主义的评论，以及杰克是美国政府间谍的事实。谢谢。嗯，谢谢你懂。谢谢你懂。还有，对，以及背景中的一切，我记得那个声音，所有的吻都是她的、他的和她的。
Yes, right. Right. Yes. That was very racy for Serbia. It was. That was good shit. No. Hey, have you ever seen the film Alfa?
是的，对。对。是的。这在塞尔维亚非常香艳。确实如此。那真是好东西。不。嘿，你看过电影《阿尔法》（Alpha）吗？
I've always wondered that. Have you ever seen that? I don't like any of the Christmas movies. No, I haven't seen it. You should try that one. That one is very, very good. Very good. The one I watched and I absolutely loved
我一直很好奇。你看过那个吗？我不喜欢任何圣诞电影。不，我没看过。你应该试试那部。那部非常、非常好看。非常好。我看过而且绝对非常喜欢的一部是
was a diva's Christmas Carol starring Diana Ross. That one is the most realistic one I've seen. I've seen so far. Excuse me for laughing. I'm not laughing. But Diana Ross, she can sing. Yep. But boy, can she act, you know?
由黛安·罗斯（Diana Ross）主演的《迪瓦的圣诞颂歌》（A diva's Christmas Carol）。那是我看过的最现实的一部。到目前为止。原谅我笑。我不是在笑。但黛安·罗斯，她真的很会唱歌。没错。但是天哪，她真会演戏，你知道吗？
Okay, well, we'll have to. We'll check that out. Yeah, please, please do. You're going to see what was it called again? A diva's Christmas Carol, Diana Ross. Sure. A diva's Christmas Carol. Okay.
好吧，那我们得去看看了。是的，请务必、务必去看看。你会看到——它叫什么来着？《迪瓦的圣诞颂歌》，黛安·罗斯。当然。《迪瓦的圣诞颂歌》。好吧。
So you don't care for any of the actors who have portrayed you in films like the... No, because it's all crap, it's all bullshit. You would think someone would get on a Zoom with me and say, hey, what's it really like? But no, you know, and whatever. I don't have time to talk about it. I know you don't have time. So let me just ask you really quick, because I know you do have to go, what are you going to go do? What do you do to go and kind of rely after your coal plunge? What do you do to kind of let the release valve, you know, do you and the misses of miss
所以你不在乎任何在电影中扮演过你的演员，比如……不，因为那都是垃圾，都是一堆狗屎。你本以为会有人跟我连线然后说，嘿，真实情况到底是怎样的？但并没有，你知道的，随便吧。我没时间谈这个。我知道你没时间。所以我只想快点问你，因为我知道你真的得走了，你接下来要去做什么？你做完冷水浴后会做什么来放松一下？你做什么来让压力释放阀，你知道的，你和圣诞老奶奶
the Santa Claus? You guys, you guys do anything to just kind of take care of. We have a time share in Boca, so we do that. But seriously, I say don't look at me till St. Patrick's Day. Okay. I just don't even look at me. You're a wreck. I'm a wreck. I'm an absolute wreck.
——圣诞老人的夫人？你们俩做点什么来照顾好自己。我们在博卡（Boca）有一个分时度假屋，我们就去那里。但说真的，我说过在圣帕特里克节之前别来找我。好吧。简直别来烦我。你崩溃了。我崩溃了。我彻底崩溃了。
Do you have kids? We've, no, we never got around you. We never got around to it. How many, how many butts, how many, how many six do you get through? Oh, I go, I go through. I mean, this is my, on my wish list, parliaments, and I go through. It must be difficult to get those things fired up once you're up there on the slate. Yep. Once you're in high altitude, you, you, you, and that's when I,
你有孩子吗？我们，没有，我们从来没抽出时间。我们从来没顾得上。多少个——多少个屁股，你抽多少盒烟？哦，我抽，我抽。我的愿望清单上就有帕liament（议会香烟），我抽得很多。一旦你上了雪橇，要把那些东西点着一定很困难吧。没错。一旦你到了高空，你，你，你——就在那个时候，
when I get that nicotine withdrawal right around Southeast Asia, it's, just go right to the patch. That's a real kick in the patch. Yes, or the gum or the gum, but the gum will get caught in the beard. Yeah. You sound a little like, well, Arnett, when you now that you're older and you're smoking more. Well, it has an effect on the vocal cords. I mean, when how old were you when you're when you're beard turned white? Uh, 19. That's 19. Who are the naughtiest kids just but it's just what area of the world do you find the naughtiest kids?
当我大约在东南亚上空产生尼古丁戒断反应时，我就，直接用尼古丁贴片。那贴片可真够劲。是的，或者口香糖，或者口香糖，但口香糖会粘在胡子里。是的。你听起来有点像阿内特（Will Arnett），当你——现在你老了，你抽烟越来越多了。嗯，这会对声带产生影响。我是说，你胡子变白的时候你多大？呃，19岁。那是19岁。哪些是最淘气的孩子，但是——世界哪个地区的孩子最淘气？
I'll give you the names right now. Ryan Carter, Patrick Russo, Gary Hampton, Tom Robinson, Alexander N Robinson. Alexander Nails. Alexander Nails. So they're getting, what do they, what do they get? Do they, John Malcolm? Do they, do they really get coal or is that just a wives tale? They get coal. They get coal. I can't find coal as easily as, and it's no one wants. Yeah, the wopsters. got rid of the coal with the mattress that weighs down the slay on the. So you know what I find that they were really bombed out about fruit. I give them fruit. Oh, give them a pineapple or a cum quad. Overly ripe or not
我现在就把名字报给你们。瑞安·卡特（Ryan Carter）、帕特里克·鲁索（Patrick Russo）、加里·汉普顿（Gary Hampton）、汤姆·罗宾逊（Tom Robinson）、亚历山大·N·罗宾逊（Alexander N Robinson）。亚历山大·内尔斯（Alexander Nails）。亚历山大·内尔斯。所以他们得到的——他们得到的是什么，约翰·马尔科姆？他们真的能得到煤炭，这只是一个老生常谈的传说吗？他们得到煤炭。他们得到煤炭。我找煤炭不像以前那么容易了，而且根本没人想要。对，那些笨蛋。用床垫代替煤炭，那会把雪橇压得……所以你知道我发现他们对水果其实很反感。我给他们水果。哦，给他们一个菠萝或者金桔。过熟的还是根本不熟
ripe at all. It can't be kept. Or a lemon, and sometimes if I put a little inscription on note, and a lemon, and I say suck it. Just a personalized. Yeah. What's the dumbest letter you ever got? Do you remember any of your dumb letters? The dumbest letter I ever got was from Jimmy Carter's brother Billy Carter. Yep. And he wanted...
的？不能留。或者一个柠檬，有时如果我在便条上写点寄语，还有一个柠檬，然后我说，吃瘪吧。只是个性化的。是的。你收过最蠢的信是什么？你还记得什么愚蠢的信吗？我收过最蠢的信是吉米·卡特（Jimmy Carter）的弟弟比利·卡特（Billy Carter）寄来的。没错。他想要——
He was already in his cups. I don't even remember what it was, but I just remember thinking, this guy's a jackass. And you know... I'm really banged up. It proved to be true. And having no kids of yourself and having only to like deal with them all these years, do you still love kids? Do you still love being around them? Like, do you look forward to this year? Look, I come off like I'm on the bad mood. I love kids. I do. The kids are why I come back to it. Yeah. Because, you know, for the most part, the kids are the they are the future, right? Right. Yes. I guess so. I mean, it feels like you're just
他当时已经喝醉了。我甚至不记得上面写的是什么了，但我只记得当时心想，这家伙真是个混蛋。你知道的……我伤得不轻。事实证明确实如此。既然你自己没有孩子，这些年来不得不和他们打交道，你还喜欢孩子吗？你还喜欢和他们在一起吗？比如，你还期待今年吗？听着，我表现得像是在发脾气。我喜欢孩子。真的。孩子们才是我重操旧业的原因。是的。因为，在大多数情况下，孩子们是——他们是未来，对吧？对。是的。我想是的。我是说，感觉你就像在
quoting a song like a Whitney Houston song. All the kids are the future. And it could get all the kids to hold hands around the world and seeing a song in harmony. Oh boy, what a better place this would be. This is a Coca-Cola. If we could get animated polar bears along with kids. Oh my God. This is a Coca-Cola. How much polar bear drank a bottle of pop?
引用一首歌，就像惠特尼·休斯顿（Whitney Houston）的歌一样。所有的孩子都是未来。如果能让全世界所有的孩子手拉手，和谐地唱一首歌。哦天哪，那这个世界该是个多么美好的地方啊。这是一则可口可乐广告。如果我们能让动画北极熊和孩子们在一起。哦，天哪。这是一则可口可乐广告。北极熊怎么会喝一瓶汽水呢？
How do you... What are you making in endorsements pre tax what are you pulling in your gross would you estimate if I'm talking euros your euros is fine we'll take it in pre tax pre tax well we are the Serbian tax systems. Yeah. Yeah. Uh, I'm making about 47 million. 47 million euros. Bro, trouble finding things to spend that on up north. I'm about to buy Chelsea. Chelsea.
你怎么……你税前代言费能赚多少，你的总收入你估计是多少？如果我说是欧元，欧元也可以，我们接受税前，税前，好吧，我们有塞尔维亚税收系统。对。对。呃，我大约赚4700万。4700万欧元。老兄，在北方很难找到花钱的地方吧。我正准备买下切尔西。切尔西。
Chelsea, Chelsea football club. Yeah, I got a bit in. So here's the thing. If I, if that goes through, right, I'm done. You're done with Christmas. I'm done with all your hand over the gig to who to the misses. I'll hand over the mid. I'll hand it over to, you know, I don't care. I'll hand it over to you three jokers.
切尔西，切尔西足球俱乐部。对，我出了个价。所以事情是这样的。如果我——如果这笔交易成了，对吧，我就不干了。你不再搞圣诞节了。我不干了，你把这个差事交接给谁——交给夫人。我把这个交接给——我不在乎。我把它交接给你们三个小丑。
If you, if you, can you make this play? If you, if you buy chill, if that ends up happening, I know it's in the works and you don't want to talk too much about it because it's still in the work. Yeah, I can't. I really can't say too much, but maybe just ask you this, if that ends up happening, I know it's in the works and you don't want to talk too much about it because it's still in the works. I can't. I really can't say too much, but maybe just ask you this, if you retain control of Chelsea football club, will you try to get American Christian policeage back on the squad? That will be my first move. That's your first move.
如果你——如果你，你能把这个演好吗？如果你——如果你买下切尔西，如果最终真的发生了，我知道这还在筹备中，你不想谈太多，因为它还在筹备中。对，我不能。我真的不能说太多，但也许只是想问你这个，如果最终真的发生了，我知道这还在筹备中，你不想谈太多，因为它还在筹备中。我不能。我真的不能说太多，但也许只是想问你这个，如果你保留对切尔西足球俱乐部的控制权，你会试图把美国人克里斯蒂安·普利西奇（Christian Pulisic）带回球队吗？那将是我的第一步。那是你的第一步。
I'm like, no, no. Yeah. Wait, Santa, I want to know, what is the, what is somebody to get you as a gift? Like, the guy who has every thing. Yeah, well, I, uh, obviously, I'm never going to say no to parliaments. Um, uh, I like a, a comfortable walking shoe. Yeah, like Clarks or a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, yeah, John Stens. Sure. I've tried the, um, well, oh gosh, what's the, uh, I should know this. How about the shoes that you don't have to reach down to put on?
我就像，不，不。是的。等等，圣诞老人，我想知道，有什么是别人能送给你的礼物吗？比如，拥有世间一切的那个家伙。是的，好吧，我——显然，我永远不会拒绝帕liament香烟；嗯，我喜欢一双舒适的步行鞋。是的，比如克拉克（Clarks）或者——呃，约翰·斯滕斯（John Stens）。当然。我试过——嗯，哦天哪，是什么——呃，我应该知道这个。那些不用弯腰就能穿上的鞋子怎么样？
Do you just kind of step it? Sure. Does work for you? I love a good schedule. Yeah. I'm doing it. There may be, I can't say anything, but fingers crossed. There may be a sketches collab with Snoop and a few two with you and me and say to Nicholas, Nicklaus and Snoop.
你只要踩进去就行了。当然。那对你有用吗？我喜欢一双好的斯凯奇（Skechers）。是的。我在穿。可能，我什么也不能说，但祈祷吧。可能会有一个斯凯奇与Snoop Dogg的合作款，还有几双关于你、我和圣诞老人尼古拉、尼克劳斯和Snoop的联名款。
Wow. Yeah. Wow. Huh. Well, we so we're making news. Is that okay to report that? That's okay. That's okay.
哇。对。哇。嗯。好吧，所以我们在爆料。报道这个可以吗？可以的。可以的。
That's that's like we're on the five yard line on that. Okay. So standing again, before we let you go, what are you looking at? What's your, what's your, what are you looking to be wheels up? Wheels up, we've got to start. Oh, God, let me see.
这就好像我们已经推进到进攻端五码线了。好吧。所以圣诞老人，在我们放你走之前，你在看什么？你的——你的——你什么时候准备出发？准备出发，我们得开始。哦，天哪，让我看看。
What's that? Yeah, no, I know. What happened? No, just the, my, my chief navigator says there's a Icelandic volcano erupted again, so we're going to have to go around. Oh, you have to circumm. Okay. So we probably have to leave 3 o'clock my time.
什么？对，不，我知道。怎么了？不，只是——我的首席领航员说冰岛又有一座火山爆发了，所以我们不得不绕道。哦，你得绕行。好吧。所以我们大概得在我的时间3点钟出发。
3pm. 3pm. You're in time. And here's another secret. In order to deliver all the toys in time, I have to do some of it in daylight and it's just, you know, wow. Oh, the kids must hate that. And the kids sometimes see me and I have to threaten them.
下午3点。下午3点。你的时间。还有另一个秘密。为了按时送达所有礼物，我必须在白天进行一部分，这简直是，你知道的，哇。哦，孩子们一定讨厌那样。有时孩子们会看到我，我不得不威胁他们。
I'm like, don't do anyone. You won't get another gift. Oh, so kids have seen you, but the reason it hasn't come out is because you've threatened that they'll never get another gift. Threaten them and I also have their little memory wiper from the back. That little sheep. Yeah, I started with you. I have that.
我对他们说，谁敢说出去，你们就再也别想拿到礼物了。哦，所以孩子们见过你，但之所以没有曝光，是因为你威胁说他们以后再也拿不到礼物了？威胁他们，而且我随身带着背后的那个小小记忆擦除器。那个小装置。对，我从你开始。我有那个。
Yeah. I have that. I have that. I love that you're Serbian. I can't wait to spread that around. Are you spending a lot of time back in Belgrade these days? Well, look, it's not a safe place to be still pretty high. Yeah, it's all. So, yes. And I, you know, I have to roll heavy when I go to the Elves look sweet. Yes, they, what they are, they're well trained. And, uh, okay.
对。我有那个。我有那个。我很高兴你是塞尔维亚人。我迫不及待要把这个消息散布出去了。你最近在贝尔格莱德呆的时间很多吗？好吧，听着，那可不是个安全的地方，局势仍然相当紧张。是的，到处都是。所以，是的。而且我，你知道的，我去的时候必须带足人手，小精灵们看起来很可爱。是的，它们——它们训练有素。而且，好吧。
And they know. Oh, they know how to handle themselves. They sure. Yes. Sure. Do you know, personally, we'll go to Belgrade. We'll go, we'll go to Nobu and we'll say how to people. Yeah, we'll do all the usual places. And maybe have a meal with with Novak, Jokovec, or you know, maybe with the Joker, you're sure. And some of Eileen Astaz is family. Oh, kidding. Yeah, that's the meaning.
而且它们知道。哦，它们知道该怎么保护自己。它们当然知道。是的。当然。你知道的，亲自去，我们会去贝尔格莱德。我们会去——我们会去松屋（Nobu），然后跟人们打招呼。是的，我们会去所有平常的地方。也许和诺瓦克·德约科维奇（Novak Djokovic）一起吃顿饭，或者你知道的，也许和“小丑”一起，当然。还有伊莲娜·阿塔齐奇（Ilean Astaz）的一些家人。哦，开玩笑的。是的，那才是重点。
But he spends time in. It comes over for the shops. And he loves shopping. Okay, well, Santa, listen, again, I obviously it's a really busy days or any message that you want to like sort of leave our listener with or the kids of the world just on this epic video. I think I said it. I want all the kids who hold hands around the world and sing a song, peace and joy and
但他花时间在。他过来逛街。他喜欢购物。好吧，圣诞老人，听着，再次说明，显然这是非常忙碌的日子，你有什么话想对我们的听众或者全世界的孩子们说的，就在这个史诗般的视频里？我想我已经说过了。我希望全世界所有的孩子都能手拉手，唱一首歌，关于和平、欢乐和
harmony. All right. Brought to us by who? Bycook. No, no, no, no, no, no. The new cook's zero, it might be, and I'm not just saying this, I'm not just saying this. It might be the best cook ever.
和谐。好的。由谁赞助的？可口可乐。不，不，不，不，不，不。全新的零度可口可乐，它可能是——我不是在开玩笑，我真的不是在开玩笑。它可能是有史以来最好的可口可乐。
I'm not just saying this. Okay. I'm not just saying it. Ah. Well listen, Santa, what a treat for us to be able to spend just a big part of Christmas. Yeah, it wasn't a treat for you to be able to spend just a bit part of Christmas. Yeah, it wasn't a treat for you as a waste of time for me. So I'm going to look, are we done?
我不是在开玩笑。好吧。我真的不是在开玩笑。啊。好吧，听着，圣诞老人，能让咱们共度圣诞节的大部分时光，对我们来说真是一种享受。对你来说可不是什么享受，对我来说简直是浪费时间。所以我要——听着，我们结束了吗？
Yeah, listen, best of luck tonight. I hope you have great work. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. So, say, oh, he's out. Oh, he's gone. You have so quickly. Well, we wish him luck.
对，听着，祝你今晚一切顺利。希望你工作愉快。对，对，对。好吧。所以，说，哦，他挂了。哦，他走了。你挂得这么快。好吧，我们祝他好运。
We'll hopefully sovers up just a little bit before he gets behind the reins. To all our fans and everywhere, from Santa, we can speak for Santa. Mary Christmas. Mary Christmas, everyone. We love you guys. Mary Christmas, you guys, I love you guys so much. Love you guys.
希望他在握住缰绳之前能稍微清醒一点。向我们所有的粉丝和各地的朋友，以圣诞老人的名义，我们可以代表圣诞老人：圣诞快乐。圣诞快乐，大家。我们爱你们。圣诞快乐，伙计们，我太爱你们了。爱你们。
Have a great, great rest of the Christmas Eve and an incredible day tomorrow. Yeah. Mary Christmas, you guys, and happy holidays. We love you. And let's just say a very, very special Christmas. Bye. Bye.
祝大家平安夜剩下的时间过得愉快，明天过得精彩绝伦。对，圣诞快乐，伙计们，节日快乐。我们爱你们。让我们共同度过一个非常、非常特殊的圣诞节。再见。再见。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. This episode was exquisitely handcrafted by our favorite Santa's digital helpers. Smart, less. If you like Smart List, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wundry Plus in the Wundry app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。本集节目由我们最喜爱的圣诞老人数字化助手精心制作。Smartless。如果你喜欢 SmartLess，现在就可以通过加入 Wondry App 或 Apple Podcasts 上的 Wondry Plus 来提前收听无广告版。Prime 会员可以在 Amazon Music 上免费收听无广告版。在离开之前，请在 Wondry.com/survey 填写简短的问卷，让我们更好地了解你。
survey. Hey, I'm Michelle Beetle. And I'm Peter Rosenberg. Hey Peter, tell the people about our new podcast. Right, it's called Over the Top. And we cover the biggest topics in sports and pop culture using royal rumble rules. That means we'll start with two stories. Toss one out on its ass and dive into the other stories with ruthless aggression. Oh, but it never stops because every 90 seconds after that.
嘿，我是米歇尔·比特尔（Michelle Beadle）。我是彼得·罗森伯格（Peter Rosenberg）。嘿，彼得，向大家介绍一下我们的新播客。没错，它叫《超越极限》（Over the Top）。我们用皇家大战的规则来探讨体育和流行文化中最热门的话题。这意味着我们将从两个故事开始。
Wow, God, whose music is that? Another story comes down to the ring. Rinse and repeat until we arrive at the one most important thing on planet Earth that week. Follow over the top on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to over the top early and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus. For the record, this is not a wrestling podcast. No, no, but it is inspired by wrestling. Isn't everything inspired by wrestling, Beetle?
把它狠狠地扔出去，然后以无情的侵略性深入探讨另一个故事。哦，但它永远不会停止，因为在那之后的每90秒。哇，天哪，那是谁的音乐？另一个故事又冲上了擂台。如此循环往复，直到我们得出那一周地球上最重要的一件事情。在 Wondry App 或你获取播客的任何地方关注《超越极限》。你可以通过加入 Wondry Plus 提前收听无广告版的《超越极限》。郑重声明，这不是一个摔角播客。不，不，不过它的灵感确实来自摔角。难道不是所有东西的灵感都来自摔角吗，比特尔？
Fair point. Yeah! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有道理。耶！本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。